well there is no sort of corner to hide
anymore we really live in your
competitor is not down the street or not
down the next date it's around the world
and so it means that you can't just be
okay anymore and I'd say in the time
period like after the I mean america
emerged out of the second world war with
the you know the greatest manufacturing
infrastructure in the world and kind of
Road on that wave for maybe 30 40 years
today we no longer have the best
manufacturing infrastructure in the
world and we have to compete with the
best and the brightest around the world
a big issue for us i think is there are
people out there that are just as smart
as us that are much hungrier than us and
much more determined to you know get
their piece of the American dream which
is no longer in America and I I think
there's the next 10 or 15 years is a
huge wake-up call for Americans to
realize that that they are competing in
a global world with with people who are
every bit as smart and probably a lot
hungrier and more dedicated to getting
up in the morning with her so the
greatest thing about America is that in
my experience when it when it it it
faces a huge sort of seemingly
unchallenged huge obstacle it figures
out how to solve that so I remember it
wasn't that long ago we don't talk about
it anymore but when people were saying
you know America had lost its edge to
Japan and Japan and turned to Korea and
some of the other sort of asian giants
and I think what turned that around is
good old sort of American okay if it's
broken we can fix it and just the kind
of willingness to take a challenge take
on a challenge head-on
and the kind of flexibility in terms of
our institutions for doing that as well
so I wouldn't count America out at all
but I do think that the world we're
competing in now and will compete in is
very different the one that we have in
Manhattan well I think those are two
countries that we are going to be
competing with in a very direct way last
January I spent some time in India and
four or five years ago there were
probably two or three people in India
who were capable of teaching
entrepreneurship at at the University of
graduate school level and I was there
doing a workshop with a with a colleague
from the London Business School and we
had a hundred and fifty professors who
were there wanting to learn sort of
pedagogical methods and tools for
teaching entrepreneurial skills in the
classroom and the enthusiasm and the
commitment to this whole new
entrepreneurial way of thinking was
palpable is just really exciting so this
is why I say there's all these folks out
there who are dedicated and hungry and
keen and and the the flow of goods and
services now around the world is it's
just under interrupted by borders